all subjects are 100% real in this room
that's how it guess what it gets how
much for this one very moving piece
$9,500 I'll take it that's right the
only problem I have with drinking is
that drinking is a matter partner
baby-talking I gotta see yes sir is your
sister Samantha Jacob stone what's going
on
I'm sorry mr. Jacobs
[Music]
so it says here the first option that
full custody of their daughter Madison
yeah and you will be accepting is the
correct except so you're the one who's
gonna be taking care of me now it's your
mom ever tell you what happened to our
parents they died in a car accident
I understand how alone think you feel
this is not our responsibility she's the
only family that I have we got an
anonymous call to the office saying that
you were doing prescription pills and
cocaine around ready that's ridiculous
who told you that they're not going to
take me away are they you promise I
promise it's so easy to not take
responsibility because then you don't
have to change anything Maddie doesn't
have a home anymore there's only one
person who can do something about it
you're hurting more people in just
yourself you know that this is just the
beginning though right
but this is a life choice you have to
stay committed to
[Music]
you
[Music]
you